let's get to five headlines
[Music]
reporting from cnn here white house
counselor kellyanne conway announced
sunday
evening that she will leave her post at
the end of the month while her husband
george conway said he was withdrawing
from the lincoln project both citing a
need to focus on their family
uh cnn continues quoting from kelly and
conway's statement
i will be transitioning from the white
house at the end of this month george is
also making changes we disagree about
plenty but we are
united on what matters most to kids our
four children are teens and tweens
starting a new academic year in middle
school and high school remotely
from home for at least a few months as
millions of parents nationwide know kids
doing a school from home requires a
level of attention and vigilance that
that is unusual at these times
um and then george conway also tweeted
that he'll be leaving the lincoln
project
um so
and this all happens uh while one of and
cnn says one of conway's high
school-aged daughters has generated
attention on social media about her
family and their political views
over the last several months now the
high school age daughter by the way
i believe is uh 15
and this is all newsworthy because of
conway's position
and the fact that she's she's leaving it
so you know fine that that part is
newsworthy but
all the rest of it the family drama the
stuff with the child
all of that is none of our business and
not relevant
to anyone else but them and the way the
media is using
a 15 year old girl to attack her parents
um well it's it's redundant at this
point to say
but the media of course has behaved
disgracefully not that they care but
just for the record once again it's
happened
and also you just so you know a 15 year
old girl
professing to hate her parents there is
nothing new about that
okay she can she can join the club with
all the other 15 year old girls
in the country now it's unfortunate that
this is a normal phase of adolescence in
in modern society and we could talk
about why that is and and you know
because i don't think it should be as
normal as is but but
it is normal um so i you know
the fact that her her parents are high
profile doesn't necessarily have
anything to do with that whatsoever
okay nhl announcer mike milburyberry has
been
taken off of all nhl broadcasts for the
remainder of the year
because of a terrible horribly offensive
thing that he said while calling a
hockey game on friday
we're gonna roll the tape on that it's
pretty rough i'm just telling you
hopefully i can play it without bleeping
it out i don't know uh but this is
really outrageous stuff
really bad take a listen come here and
play hockey
if you think about it it's a terrific
environment with regards to
if you enjoy playing and enjoy being
with your teammates for long periods of
time it's a perfect place
not even any woman had to disrupt their
concentration
yeah that's it that's the whole thing
that was it
um millbury said that it's good there
aren't women there because
uh then they won't be disrupting the
hockey player's concentration
that was all that was the joke harmless
innocuous
nothing to it but that was shared by a
female
i believe is a female nhl reporter who
was deeply offended
and then a bunch of other women all
chimed in to say they're deeply
deeply offended uh here's emily kaplan
another nhl reporter
talking about her own deep offense which
she feels so deeply and so offendedly
listen to be honest it's highly
disappointing it undermines anything
that any woman who is in this industry
does you know the athletic came out with
their 40 people
in hockey under the age of 40 and i was
just impressed by how many women were on
that list
whether it was from scouting ranks
analytics um now we have an agent who's
going to represent the likely number one
pick and then the lee kesten gaye
and when i look at meg milbury this is a
pattern of behavior this is not the
first time he's made sexist comments it
was so cavalier and natural the way he
said it
and he's in such a position of privilege
and power
there's so few people who do what he
does and i just think it's a shame
that we're giving someone like that a
platform when they continue to say these
things
and alienate large swaths of people who
can be hockey fans and can enjoy this
great sport
um and you know i hope that nbc takes
that into consideration
you know he said well there's no
distractions to women in the bubble and
i think he's talking about wives and
spouses but
also at press conferences and i think
okay i'm a woman that shows up for the
press conference does he consider me a
distraction if i'm in the locker room
like
that's bs that's my job um so yeah you
know that makes me feel like hockey is
not for me or i'm not welcome and you
know we have these conversations a lot
about race we do have about gender we
have it about sexuality
and i think the important thing is that
we keep having these conversations
and we keep the league needs to keep
their eye on the prize and keep their
eye on the ball and keep doing with
initiatives even if we don't have change
right away
that doesn't mean we can stop oh my gosh
uh
you know this the irony here is that all
of this only proves
millbury's point all of these women
getting emotional and crying about
a joke or it proves a similar point i
should say
i think what millbury was getting at was
that women can distract men
sexually which actually is a compliment
to women if a man says that he's
distracted by your beauty
that's a compliment you know i think i
think
any any man in the country would love to
be told that by women
you know you know how any man would feel
if they walked in and there's a group of
women and and he was
there he's told that he's a distraction
because he's so good looking um
that's uh that's a compliment so and
and i sometimes wonder the type of women
who get offended by these kinds of jokes
are they getting offended because they
never hear comments like that and are
jealous
is there some envy going on i don't know
it's just it's one theory
but um there's another reason why a
group of men
might want to just have some time
without the girls
and the reason is this so they can joke
around and have some fun
and say what they want without anyone
getting emotional or taking things
too seriously now granted with the state
of masculinity in this country
that's no guarantee anymore just because
it's a bunch of guys doesn't mean that
you're not going to end up with someone
crying and getting emotional these days
but still the the likelihood is is
reduced dramatically if it's just the
guys around
so as i said the irony is that these
feminists are only proving the point
exactly
and i'll tell you another thing if
you're a female sports reporter
and you want to be accepted
then pretty much the last thing you
should do is start crying
because a harmless innocuous comment
that you heard is sexist according to
you
like when you start ranting about male
privilege
do you really think the guys are going
to want you around why would they
they're trying to play hockey why would
they why would they particularly want
someone around to lecture them about
about the patriarchy
and and sexism and male privilege and
and you know toxic masculinity
um it's just it's probably not something
they want any more than if you're a
woman and you're out with the girls
do you want a guy around to tell fart
jokes
like when you're sitting around at the
at the the winery or whatever you're
doing
is anyone at the table saying hey you
know i wish there was a guy here to
fart that's what we're missing
probably not so okay uh let's go to our
next so i think this is what is this
number three uh i hate to be the bearer
of bad news here but you may
have heard about this asteroid that
might hit the earth the day before the
election day
great timing of course but turns out
it's only six feet long
and um has less than a one percent
chance of hitting and you know so it's
like it's six feet
even if it hits what are the chances
that it does any significant damage
um so i'm sorry to ruin your monday at
this point i feel like the universe is
just
toying with us sort of tormenting us
dangling these asteroids in front of us
like hey
bet you like this wouldn't you sorry
it's hitting mercury instead
and then and then we you know to make it
worse we we look out at the night sky
and we see the moon over there flaunting
its crater covered
body bragging at all the time
and we have to see that and it's just
really it's real it's difficult for me
i'm sure it is for you as well
okay let's go uh number four here police
arrested
two women in delaware who stole a
seven-year-old's trump hat outside the
dnc
um the boy and his mom were protesting
outside the dnc
and uh then here's the altercation that
was caught on tape by the boy's mom and
led to the arrest watch
back you get off my property get off my
coffee are you destroying my property
yes we are
you know that's a felony that one too
get away from the [ __ ] out get it liam
get it
touch my heart
get your hat back baby look at what you
just did to my
get your hat back baby get your hat back
baby
give me back my hat give me back my hat
give me back my hat give me back my hat
give me back my hat give me back my hat
give me back my
okay so i'm glad that the the two trashy
women there
got got arrested and they were obviously
wrong for taking the boy's hat
bullying a seven-year-old boy when
you're an adult is clearly
i don't know how to explain why that's
wrong but the mother is no victim in
this let's just be clear about that as
well
the boy is a victim but he's a victim of
all three women involved
the mother and the two others so let me
just state this very simply
there is no good reason no good reason
ever to involve your young children in
politics
bringing a seven-year-old boy to
counter-protest
the dnc convention and dressing him in
trump gear
is an absolutely inexcusably crappy
parenting decision
i would never in a million years do that
i have seven year olds i go into
contentious environments where there
might be serious pushback whether it's a
protest or i'm speaking out of college
or something
you know um and uh
i would never bring my kid and it's not
that if i brought my kid and my kid was
attacked uh you know it's it's i'm
it's it's like it's not the fault of the
protesters for doing no it would be
their fault
but i'm not gonna bring my kid into some
sort of guinea pig i'm not going to take
a
gamble take a chance i would never ever
do that
why because i love my kids i want to
keep them out of harm's way
there's just no possible way that this
could benefit them
it's you know there's only downside
there's no upside whatsoever
so leave your kids out of politics just
leave them out of this garbage
and and using your kid as bait to get a
reaction
so you can film it for clicks which i
believe is what happened here let's not
be naive is disgusting
and i hate it i hate everything about it
i mean
notice how the mom actively involves the
kid every step of the way so go get your
your hat back baby go get your hat back
no you get it back you're the adult what
do you send it a seven-year-old to go
retrieve his stolen property from an
adult
that would be like if i was in my house
and i looked out my window and i saw uh
you know
my kid's bike is on the front lawn i see
a man drive up and try to steal the bike
and i yelled at myself hey go go get
your bike go get your bike go
get it i'll wait in here and film it
this will be good for youtube
no um i wouldn't do that because again i
care about my children's well-being i'm
the adult
if there's an adult situation i will
handle it
i keep my kids out of it and that's what
we should all do
let your kids be kids your
seven-year-old doesn't need to be
spending his nights
holding signs outside the dnc he doesn't
even understand what the signs say or
anything he doesn't know anything about
this
he's seven years old he should be
running around the yard you know making
a tree fort or something
even playing video games would be better
than this let him be a kid just let him
alone
for god's sake all right finally let's
go to this i thought this was just
wonderful in many ways and also
relatable
i've never related to lebron james
really at all
uh until i saw this clip
so you're holding the autobiography of
malcolm x along with alex haley i don't
know how far you are into the book but
what's your biggest takeaway so far
um i kind of just started a couple days
ago um
but um i've read a lot of a lot of notes
over the years
it's my first time actually reading this
from start to finish
but just a very um very smart man
very very very smart man and basically
his words in the in the 60s and
what was going on is actually what's
going on today
still him understanding
the how powerful
the negro can be we use that word a lot
how powerful we are um
but we have to unite and uh we have to
be together we have to stand strong
because there's always going to be
obstacles there's also be um
you know things that's going to be
thrown at us where they try to weaken us
they try to fill up make us feel like
we're not kings and queens
and it's going to come from all you know
different races and different
shapes and sizes and things of that
nature
and just a very powerful minded
gentleman that's that's just great there
i mean he didn't read the book at all
obviously and the first clue is that
he's holding it
during the post-game conference with
like why does he have his book with him
did he think he was going to be able to
read a few chapters in between each
question
um but like i said i relate to that
painfully so it reminds me of well
pretty much every day in english class
when i was
when i was a kid a teacher would call on
me so so matt we were
supposed to read chapter three of to
kill a mockingbird last night what were
your impressions of the chapter
um chapter three oh yeah well geez
chapter three my goodness chapter three
am i right
chapter three it's just you know the
main thing about chapter three is just
like it's it's it's it's it's like
it's you're you're part of the way into
the story but you're not but there's
still so much of the story and so like
there's so much that's that's happening
that has happened and but there's a lot
that will happen
and so the main thing is just like the
three-ness of chapter three
is what jumps out at me you know
um and it never i i never got i got
better at bsing as i got older
uh but uh i never got much better than
that unfortunately and neither did
lebron james
but i will mention just one note for the
kids uh if when you have school reading
you should actually do it don't take
your lessons from me and actually i
discovered
um when i left school that i really
enjoy reading
i just enjoy it when i'm not being
forced to do it and i can read books
that i really care about so it's funny
how that works anyway
uh so there's maybe uh we'll have to
check in with lebron james in a little
bit to get his full book report
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content